elle s'appelle li na no 7 au soleil au
mig ma ce prénom n'est pas celui qu'elle
a reçus à la naissance mais comme pour
beaucoup d'autochtones choisir un prénom
traditionnel lui a permis d'écrire sa
propre histoire celle d'une femme
d'origine crie forte et lumineuse 7 est
né en 1970 à thompson manitoba à trois
ans elle se retrouve dans une famille
juive montréalaise sud mais elle fait
partie des quelques 20 mille enfants
autochtones enlevés à leurs parents
entre les années 60 et 80 pour être
adoptée dans des familles blanches
c'est ce qu'on a appelé la rafle des
années 60
le prétexte était de sortir ses enfants
de milieux de vie malsain l'une des
conséquences a été l'effacement de leurs
cultures
à l'adolescence nagusa rêve de découvrir
qui elle est réellement
[Musique]
à 22 ans elle est mannequin et sa quête
d'identité se reflète même à travers les
contrats qu'elle accepte
c'est à cette époque qu'elle apprend que
depuis les temps immémoriaux dans
plusieurs nations autochtones
ce sont les aînés qui attribue plus nos
enfants et nous originaire de pessah
need grégoire canapé et haut de ses
leaders spirituels qui pratiquent des
cérémonie d'attribution prénom pour lui
un prénom autochtone change tout c'est
vraiment au niveau de la fierté
culturelle au niveau d'apple au niveau
de ton identité mais c'est grâce à cette
pratique traditionnelle qu'elle trouvera
le chemin vers son identité
elle se tourne vers un aîné pour obtenir
un nouveau prénom
jusqu'aux années 80 ce qui souhaitait
inscrire ces prénoms traditionnels à
l'état civil
ce but est souvent à l'église il ya eu
certaines avec france au niveau des
débris de dizaines l'avaient vous
d'autres non il voulait pas vraiment
qu'on donne des noms octobre
mais des familles ont résisté dans celle
du web guichet kreis originaire de la
première nation rosso xing en ontario à
la fin des années 70 john reiss le père
de web guichet qu a voulu que son fils
soit lié à sa culture
il a donc demandé à sa mère de lui
choisir un prénom anishnabe cette
tradition culturelle avaient été perdus
dans leurs familles en raison du
colonialisme ans aujourd'hui web guichet
kreis porte fièrement son prénom qui
réfère à la couleur du ciel avant l'aube
à la naissance de ses fils wang échec a
poursuivi la tradition
il a fait appel à son père john pour
qu'il le retrouve des prénoms anishnabe
il les annonay djigui ce qui veut dire
premier-né et aya baisse petit chevreuil
est par ailleurs les garçons ne porte
pas le nom de famille reiss mais
menominee c'est celui qui avait un
ancêtre paternel avant que le
gouvernement canadien ne le force à le
traduire en anglais web riches etc et sa
femme tout comme d'autres membres de sa
famille ont voulu faire revivre ce nom
en 2015 les commissaires de la
commission de vérité et de
réconciliation sur les pensionnats
autochtones ont souligné l'importance de
reprendre légalement un non autochtone
elle a recommandé aux provinces et
territoires d'exempter les survivants et
leurs familles des frais liés à ce
changement d'identité
à ce jour seule l'alberta la nouvelle
écosse l'ontario et les territoires du
nord-ouest l'ont fait à partir d'un
prénom nagusa est à trouver sa place
dans le monde
militer pour les droits des autochtones
et des itinérants et dirigé le refuge
pour femmes autochtones de montréal ont
donné un sens à sa vie
un travail qu'elle souhaite faire encore
longtemps pour pouvoir à son tour aider
les autres
[Musique]